I'm joined today by a bee-sh actor who
is author of no child left alone getting
government out of parenting Abbey it's
great to talk to you I've looked at the
book extensively and I'm very very
interested in a lot of the sort of
examples that you tell in the book about
what you consider to be sort of extreme
government overreach into parenting but
I'd like to start a little more broadly
which is what sort of the the larger
statement you're trying to make about
the government's role in parenting in
the United States well the first
statement I want to make is that the
government has taken on a huge role in
parenting I think raising awareness of
the problem would be my first goal and
then beyond that I would say the problem
with that isn't just a matter of where
parents may differ from government
prescriptions but also that the
government tends to do things very
broadly by definition and that tends to
make them make it a poor problem solver
in many cases because some of the
problems or issues that they're trying
to solve are much more complicated than
can be legislated I would say and then
also there's cost
there's inefficiencies and then the
overarching sort of I would say you know
there's there's no reason in many of
these cases for the government to have
an opinion in many in many areas and we
just tend to accept that it does and I'm
hoping that that'll slowly change with
greater awareness of the problem so are
you coming at this from I mean in being
familiar with your other work I'm I
would want to first ask do you generally
consider yourself like a small
government conservative is that your
general
approach the government should not do
anything that is not absolutely
necessary so to speak no because I think
that would be a really unachievable goal
at this point so I'm a I'm a libertarian
and broadly speaking in terms of
domestic policy and I sort of I embrace
the idea that Americans should be
trusted to run their own lives in as
many cases as possible so what about
with cases of for example child abuse I
mean certainly there are parents who say
listen if I believe that my child is
going to do best in the world
if I bring him or her up with spankings
and maybe the spankings are an open hand
or maybe the spankings are a closed hand
or maybe they're a stick or maybe
they're an iron or something like that
is it fair in your mind for the
government to say above and beyond our
sort of general laws about what
constitutes a physical assault in public
that we're going to establish some
guidelines for what physically is
allowed to parents to do to their kids
are you okay with that conceptually
absolutely and and in fact there was a
recent case in Massachusetts that was
exactly this type of thing a man had
disciplined his daughter with an open
hand he'd physically hit her in public
and he was he was charged as a result of
this assault essentially and the the
state it went went to the to the state
courts and they ruled in the father's
favor basically defining his right to
discipline his child with an open hand
one of the problems that I that I
encountered doing the research for this
book is if all the that over time many
definitions of care for children have
been expanded so the word abuse the word
neglect the word endangerment
these are terms that have come to mean
much more a much broader series of
possible circumstances than they were
original than they were originally okay
well let's pause on that because I wanna
be I'm hearing what you're saying and
what I'm hearing is big-picture you are
okay with the government taking some
positions and getting involved in
certain areas of what a parent may or
may not do with relation to their child
so once once you accept that we're
really dealing in shades of gray right
and now it comes down to what
specifically do you were don't you think
is okay in the definition so once we get
into a discussion of shades of gray then
who should enforce those shades of gray
who should decide on them in your mind
given that you've accepted some
legislation is okay mm-hmm well listen I
um I think that I I accept the Supreme
Court's definition of the rights of
parents to parent to to have authority
and discretion over their children the
exception that the Supreme Court made
and this was a hundred years ago
basically was that parents are
responsible for educating their children
I think that is a terrific standard
right so if you want to argue that it's
if you want if it makes you more
comfortable to say we're talking about
shades of gray I would say we have to
start from the from the understanding
that we're not talking about a situation
where it's sort of the middle piece that
we're discussing it's really a pendulum
that has swung very very far in the
direction of government oversight and
it's going to take a lot of work by many
many people to push the needle back to a
situation where where we would get to a
point of saying it's just these sort of
nuances where we need to define terms I
get the problem I have with
argument though Abbi is what what you're
basically saying is okay we are sort of
you know what you say if I'm more
comfortable saying we're talking if [ __ ]
in shades of gray
I think you've confirmed we are talking
about shades of gray but your concern is
more with the instances sort of at the
extremes and you outline some of them in
your book the problem I have with that
general principle which is the big
problem is with what's on the fringes is
that many libertarians and I'm not
accusing you of this but I'd be open to
hearing your view about it when they
talk about gun control they say we
actually should not be worried about
what's going on on the fringes right all
of the negligent incidents that happen
based on what we have is generally
pretty permissive gun laws they want to
focus on the fact that mostly it's okay
and it seems sort of like the opposite
principle okay well let me since my
subject isn't gun control I'm gonna take
what you're saying and put it to to my
argument about parenting yeah or I guess
let me rephrase it in a way that maybe
makes it more in your wheelhouse which
is as a general rule when you look at
law and the government do you always
focus merely on these fringe cases right
well so the interesting thing about that
is that the government is the one doing
that in terms of parenting decisions so
if you look at this the National School
Lunch Program right the National School
Lunch Program is based on a model that
there is a minority of a minority of
kids who may be at risk for becoming
obese and as a result we're going to
impose that extreme minority possibility
and risk or that even if it wasn't an
extreme that minority possibility on
everyone and that's where I have the
problem I think it's actually the
government that is most often taking the
minority and extreme cases
and saying because we don't want that to
happen we're going to impose that the
exception and make the exception the
rule ah so select for example and I'm
trying to really find what analogies
there are to see if we have sort of a
consistent principle with the issue of
transgender bathroom policy when there
is a presentation made that says hey you
know really people in the interest of
not creating more laws and restrictions
let people use the bathroom for the
gender identity that that matches up
with them you have some typically on the
political right who say no there's child
predators who might take advantage of
these laws or etc those are definitely
the fringes I mean it is almost
completely unheard of you would be
completely against using that that line
of reasoning to restrict bathroom usage
for example yes so my answer to that
would be why is the government involved
in private enterprises and the signs
they put on their bathrooms all right if
the government wants to make sure that
in you know in the federal office
buildings or in state office buildings
they change the signs on their bathroom
doors so that legislators are going into
and aides are are all the people who
work for you know in in a public
institution are going into a bathroom
that says you know bathroom with urinal
bathroom without urinal ok great make
make the sign however you want it but
but why is the government telling
private enterprises the kind of signs on
the bathrooms they have to they have to
provide if I mean this should be a this
is exactly the area where I would say
this is it's none of the government's
business to impose its view about
transgendered Americans on on private
enterprises
alright good well we agree there in the
limited time we have left to go back to
the school lunch example are you okay I
mean to some extent you must grant that
schools do have to make decisions about
what's available for lunch right I mean
on that some someone has to have to make
some decision and if you are okay with
that then again it's sound
like what we're talking about is you
don't believe the specifics they've
chosen make sense so it's really a
matter just of people coming together
and saying what particulars make sense
it's not really an argument saying
schools shouldn't have any authority
over what lunches serve and then again
we are talking about shades of gray are
we not yes and I would say in that case
100% David and I would say the the the
response I would give to that is you are
a hundred percent right it's the
school's who should be deciding what
they serve in their cafeterias not the
state's not the US Department of
Agriculture which is which are which is
the in the organization and the arm of
the government that does decide and does
set the nutritional guidelines for the
entire contrary and it has the USDA has
a lot of other considerations it's
making besides the nutritional health of
students of children in America and by
the way they got it wrong about butter
for 30 years you know the government has
gotten it wrong about just butter
so let's schools let the people who are
actually going to feed the children
these lunches decide what to see them
yeah I mean I'm not against that you
know like like with many libertarian
influenced ideas I'm not against what
you're saying in the abstract the
problem is knowing what goes on in many
specific school districts a lot of them
just don't have the right people there
to actually make good decisions for the
kids and that is that becomes more of a
logistical issue than than the
ideological issue that you're talking
about well I I don't have any I don't
disagree with that except that I would
say why would you assume that someone's
sitting in an office in Washington sure
has a better sense of how to make lunch
for a kid in middle school in Portland
Oregon than a person who is in Oregon no
right it's a fair question the person in
Washington
the person Washington the person in
Washington might not necessarily know
more than the person in Portland but in
many cases they probably do and that's
why this is difficult because the the
general point is the person in
Washington won't always make the
decision that's better for the person in
Portland and and really for me the
question is pragmatically speaking how
do we ensure that for the school
districts that really don't have anyone
who's well qualified to make decisions
about lunches how do we make sure that
the kids in those school districts are
still having healthy options and and
this becomes more an issue of
bureaucracy and logistics than anything
else well I do I do also I would just
disagree in in one aspect and that is
you're essentially saying that you don't
trust other people well you're saying
the same thing you don't you don't trust
the person in Washington and I don't
trust the fact that every school
district might not have a nutritionist
on staff so my question would be given
the cost and given the inefficiencies
and given the fact that we have the
situation that we have now where there
are schools that are actually suffering
because of the demands of the federal
government and it's it's costing them
money and it's making their lives more
difficult rather than simpler aren't the
odds of bringing the solution to the
particular problem closer to the people
it will affect and therefore give the
people it affects more of an apostle 'ti
of accountability right if I have to go
to my cafeteria lady right I'm a mom of
schoolchildren and I hate what they're
serving in my school cafeteria yeah I'm
likely to have a better chance of
getting better food in my kids school if
the lunch lady who's serving it is in
charge of the decision of what to serve
rather than somebody who's 3,000 miles
away yeah I don't know I think it
depends on the lunch lady but that again
I think that that might have to be an
argument for another time Abby shackles
I make my kids lunches so I'm clearly
not trusting you know the hot lunch
that's provided at my kids school right
well it's great that you can do that not
all parents are in that position the
book is no child left alone getting
government out of parenting I go we did
agree on some things and I think that
anytime I interview a libertarian that
we have to chalk it up to a victory you
know listen I appreciate the fact that
you wanted to do the interview in the
first place so kudos all right thank you
so much for going on